here we go panthers i thought they were
going to win last night i always get a
little salty on friday when i get the
first game of the week wrong i have 0
for one going into the bulk of the
schedule
the panthers were
better than i thought they were going to
be all year long they've shown me
something they've shown me in the rest
of the league how to properly rebuild
but they ran into it last night with the
falcons team that frankly when you look
at the falcons and how they've performed
this year they've done plenty of falcons
things peter they didn't last night they
held their lead late which was
impressive but i look at what they've
done where they've been
they should have five wins this year and
i think anytime they have a game that
goes well they invite
the incessant criticism of why the hell
didn't you do that the other games where
you held a lead but you fell apart last
night good news they didn't
well they got some help from teddy
bridgewater late obviously mike this was
setting up to be exactly what the
atlanta falcons season
had been
you know i do not have any understanding
you know i mean you know kevin cash and
raheem morris had a lot in common with
decisions they made
at cash late remorse early
why in the world after you go for it on
fourth and five four days ago
at the 13-yard line do you at the
three-yard line when it's fourth and six
inches kick the field goal i mean you
know what what is it which
what do you
what are you the daring guy
or the ridiculously safe guy
and then
you know later
obviously
when coup misses the extra point to keep
it a one score game at the end
all i could say was
they are setting this up to be another
ridiculous game
that they lost that they never should
have lost
but uh teddy bridgewater's late
interception uh basically
helped them from snatching defeat from
the jaws of victory
yeah and
that whole when to go for it on fourth
down when not to go forward on fourth
down i understand that analytics has
taken on greater significance than ever
but i don't need a board to tell me i'm
a one win team i've got a great drive
going i'm inside the five it's fourth
and short
of course i'm going for it what the hell
else do i have to lose i'm going for it
in that spot if i don't get it the other
team gets the ball for the first time
that night inside their own five let's
go play defense and get the ball back
hopefully with a short field and peter
to flip it around and it was a comical
moment last night where
the panthers had fourth and short in the
vicinity of the 50 maybe just on the
other side of the 50 and they sent out
the punt team and troy aikman and joe
buck were saying well you know the
analytics would say this is a spot where
you go for it and then lo and behold in
comes the offense and they go for it and
it didn't work
it didn't work and and see that's the
thing it's this complicated store of
factors ultimately driven by how do you
feel about the play that's available
that night with your offense against
their defense do you think it will work
whatever the charts say do you think
that play will work because the chart
says you should do it if you've got 10
000 different times to do it and over
the long haul it's going to work out in
your favor but in that moment it didn't
work so that that's that's where the
rubber meets the road on all of this
because most coaches don't have the
luxury of running this model 10 000
times and realizing that yes
a slim percentage of times means they
should do it every time sometimes you
just shouldn't do it
you know mike i was reminded when you
were talking of the new england atlanta
super bowl
when after the game josh mcdaniels told
me because that was the game where they
had to make a couple of two-point plays
to send the game to overtime and then
josh mcdaniels liked his two-point plays
so much
that week with james white particularly
he liked his two-point plays so much
that he ran one of the two-point plays
to win the super bowl
and and so and it goes to
knowing
your personnel
what do you have now
did matt rule have second thought
because he said well you know i don't
really trust mike davis to get i think
that was two yards by the way when it
when it was fourth down
but did he trust mike davis to do it or
did he even trust teddy bridgewater
uh you know to roll out and throw it to
an inexperienced tight end or somewhere
in the intermediate part of the field
whatever but
my point is you have to know who you
have and who you like and that's why
when
when the falcons kick the field goal
on fourth and inches from the three yard
line
when you have todd gurley julio jones
uh and you've got great skill players
i just you know i mean sometimes you
just have to shake your head that's all
julio jones had a great night last night
by the way seven catches 137 yards
matches randy moss all time for games of
125 yards or more matt ryan played
extremely well although no touchdown
passes in one interception he completed
21 of 30 passes
todd gurley 18 carries 46 yards he had a
touchdown a touchdown that he was
supposed to score he did have a moment
though late in the game
that gave the panthers
their chance to try to tie it up now
it wasn't going to end the game if he'd
stayed in bounds it just would have
given the panthers less time the falcons
could have bled another 40 seconds off
the clock it would have been closer to
the two-minute warning when the panthers
started to drive from inside their own
five because there was a questionable
fair catch on the punt that ensued but
when you run a toss play toward the
sideline it's hard to dump on todd
gurley for
not staying in bounds if you want to be
sure that the clock is going to keep
running peter you just run it up the
middle in that spot
mean i do think it's i think it's easy
to dump on todd gurley i don't care what
the call is
lie down on the field when you're five
yards from the boundary
that's all there is to it you've got to
know what to do in that situation
and the same way that uh that gurley
didn't do the right thing on sunday he
didn't do the right thing on thursday
either
and even without those flaws and
questionable things that occurred the
falcons did find a way wired like they
like they do plenty hey they're hey
they're dominating falcons are looking
good here the falcons are looking good
and then something happens to cause it
all to fall apart last night was one of
the times where it didn't fall apart 36
and a half minute time of possession for
the atlanta falcons 401 total yards
nearly 100 more than the panthers there
was that moment where teddy bridgewater
exited the game the hit from charles
harris that that got harris ejected
brought philip walker the xfl phenom
onto the field for a while
last night before teddy was able to come
back in you know that's two of those
we've seen in five days and then at a
time when there's an obsession to
protect quarterbacks we we still see
and you know what it's it's it's weird
when it's near the sideline
that's when defensive players get
discombobulated we have not seen
defensive players get discombobulated
with these plays in the middle of the
field we've seen two illegal hits hits
that resulted in ejection just in the
past few days
and you know mike i think one of the
things that is going to get looked at by
the competition committee by the way in
the off season
is and
you know patrick mahomes started to make
it famous in the afc championship game
last year against tennessee when he ran
toward the sidelines and everybody said
well you know he's going to get out of
bounds and at the last possible second
he veered up field and scored a
touchdown and everybody said including
me man brilliant play
and yes it was a brilliant play
but
i believe that a lot of times
defensive players who have momentum to a
ball carrier whether it be a quarterback
or otherwise
right at the boundary
and the guy steps out of bounds and all
of a sudden the first reaction of the
side judge or the line judge is to pull
out the flag and throw it we see it all
the time and i'm not saying i mind that
mike but what i am saying is that you
know if it is the clear intention of the
quarterback to be sprinting for the
boundary and then at the last possible
second
he puts his foot in the ground and goes
up field well
i i mean if you're a defensive player
what do what exactly are you supposed to
do
are you supposed to stop your momentum
and allow the quarterback then or the
running back whatever to go up field and
i think you're gonna see the competition
committee ask maybe there's nothing you
can do about this
but i do think that there are some
unfair burdens on the defense now that
that play is becoming more and more
popular
well if nothing else a point of emphasis
that when there is contact with a
quarterback who becomes a runner not
while he's behind the line of scrimmage
in a passing posture but when he chooses
to forfeit those protections and become
a running back that extra bubble that
the officials want to put around him
needs to go away it just needs to go
it's unfair to everyone and the moment
for me
notwithstanding the times we've seen
quarterbacks do the okie doke at the
sideline and keep running because the
defensive players pull up i remember
noticing it for the first time last year
week one when matt ryan did it to the
vikings he was doing the slow jog toward
the sideline the vikings pull up and he
darts forward for 10 more yards
when you see lamar jackson and you hear
lamar jackson
miked up saying that he flopped and
picked up 15 extra yards that's when the
nfl does need to take notice of this
peter because it does become an
integrity of the game question if you
have quarterbacks who are deliberately
and intentionally taking a dive and
picking up 15 yards in the process and
it's funny there was a moment last night
it didn't get mentioned during the
broadcast all we knew is there was a
flag that was thrown and then the flag
was picked up
but alex mack tried to flop and it was
an all-timer and i was disappointed we
didn't get a few replays of it there was
just a little mild shove
by a carolina defensive player and and
mac did the ric flair face plant it was
ju it was a thing of beauty and it
almost drew the 15 yards but you know if
we are going to have those kinds of
efforts maybe and we've seen it in other
sports where you get penalized for play
acting
for flopping i don't know how the nfl
needs to solve this but we are crossing
over into a boundary where we've got
guys who think there's a benefit in
acting like they got an illegal hit when
maybe they didn't and it all goes into
this broader bucket of
how do you deal with guys who are near
the boundary especially when it's
quarterbacks
well mike i i got i have a solution for
this you know the solution is
shawn hockey lee i think he was the
referee last night the solution is sean
hockely going up to alex mack after he
sees something like that and said
alex if you do that again i'm calling
you for 15 yards or if you do that again
i'm gonna do x you know i'm going to
eject you whatever it is you know
there's enough violence in this game
without you faking more of it so
and i did i uh to be honest why not why
not throw the flag why not throw the why
not throw the flag when they do it
that's the thing why not because you
don't want to see the guy flopped
many times
maybe you do and if you do then that's
fine with me but at the very least you
have to tell the flopper that there are
going to be consequences if i see you do
that again ref
you know officials all the time
talk to players on the field i remember
a few years ago when i did the the
series on a week in the life of the
officiating crew and i had gene
sterritor's crew and i was able because
you can't talk to officials for the most
part and i was able to talk to every
official on their crew spent a day with
five of them during the week and the one
thing that i walked away with
knowing that i know differently now is
how much
officials talk to players
about hey listen i'm gonna throw on you
if you do that if i see that one more
time or you need to get on the line of
scrimmage you're too far back they tell
tackles that all the time when they are
fanned out a yard and a half behind the
center you know and so they they give
them a little bit of warning and they
sometimes will go tell the coaches hey
coach listen if your tackle doesn't get
on the line of scrimmage on the next
play i'm thrown for illegal formation
and so that is the kind of thing that
officials do and quite honestly that the
nfl wants them to do because for the
most part the nfl doesn't want a flag
fest the atlanta falcons have made it to
two and six through eight games they
were six and two to close out the final
eight games of last season here's matt
ryan team quarterback and 2016 nfl mvp
talking about what last night's victory
could mean down the stretch
we've been in every game we played this
year
you know and so
[Music]
we've had some crazy losses you know
just to to be frank and and i really
believe that we've got the you know
caliber of team
to go be in every game we're going to
play the rest of the season and and why
can't we win them all you know that's
that's the mindset that i have
i i love these zoom video conferences
the different looks i i felt like he
should be letting the people in the back
know my order that i want a burger and
fries and a milkshake
everything everything about it it's
everyone is different than snowflakes
here's the thing about the atlanta
falcons and this is the point where they
need to get the bingo cards ready
because i'm taking a look at the atlanta
falcons upcoming schedule and
unfortunately for them they've already
exhausted their chances to pile up
victories
there's bingo oh bingo we've got
we've got a mini buy and then the
broncos okay hey maybe we can get to
three and six through nine then comes
the real bye week and they're gonna need
it because peter over the final seven
games
they play the saints
twice
they play the bucks
twice
and the chiefs
and the chargers who are pretty damn
good oh and the raiders get thrown in
there my goodness all the squandered
opportunities earlier in the season
and now they are not it is the meat
grinder down the stretch are you kidding
me
saints twice from week 11 on bucks twice
from week 11 on who gets
who ends up with a better record in this
division the falcons are the panthers
the panthers are now three and four
the amazing thing about that schedule
mike is that
they play
the bucks
twice in two weeks to end the season and
they play the saints twice in two weeks
in 15 days okay so in the span of 15
days they come out of there by and play
the saints twice and then in the span of
15 days they end the season with the
bucks and so you know
raheem morris
you know when he took the job everybody
was saying well you know he's got 11
games now he can or 12 games whatever it
was he can you know he can impress his
bosses and everything and
and i just looked at the schedule that
day and i said man he better impress him
before the buy
because after the buy it's going to be
really ugly we'll see
you know atlanta is the type of team
mike that they're gonna win one of those
games they're such a strange strange
group but if their offensive unit is
healthy if calvin ridley is not really
hurt bad and he's able to come back
they're gonna win one of those games
that's just because they're the falcons
one of those games they're going to put
up 35. that's and their defense will
win a game at the edge of the cliff in
the fourth quarter
but there will be more they're going to
win a lot of those games
there will be moments where the folks
who run the excellent falcons twitter
page will be able to use the gift that
was posted last night from the princess
bride prince humperdinck
because
yeah and i love that account i love that
they're so self-aware there was a game
recently where i think it was the
cardinals cowboys
11 days ago cardinals up 28.3 and the
falcons posted we know we know
[Laughter]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports